I'm so curious this social experiment
you see a stranger with a Boog Round of
Applause people who were telling that
person I'm not telling a stranger
anything if we're having if you're a
stranger and we're having a conversation
I will be you know I'll be the nice guy
and be like hey man I I just want to
tell you like you got something on your
teeth or you got a Boog right but if
we're just walking down the street and I
see a dude with a Boog in his nose I'm
not going to stop him and be like hey
was staring at you walking down the
street just wanted to let you know
massive one right there in the right
nostril I'm 100% walked away like what
what if he's going on a first date where
you know what you don't know where that
kid he should have checked the mirror
first he's going to get a bank loan a
bank loan for a business and the
Banker's
like yeah he should have prepared better
and checked theing mirror before he left
his house I I just learned something new
about you sure
okay
yeah I I thought everybody would tell a
stranger no no no okay all right